good morning believe nation I want you
today to add more bad influences to your
life I can explain what I mean by that
but first I want to show you an
interesting clip from Bill Gates
I want to thank Harvard for this honor
I'll be changing my job next year and it
will be nice to finally have a college
degree on my resume I applaud the
graduates for taking a much more direct
route to your degrees from our my part
I'm just happy that the Crimson called
me Harvard's most successful dropout I
guess that makes me valedictorian of my
own special class I did the best of
everyone who fail
but I also want to be recognized as the
guy who got Steve Ballmer to drop out of
Business School
I'm a bad influence that's why I was
invited to speak at your graduation if
I'd spoken at your orientation fewer of
you might be here today so it's time to
add some more bad influences to your
life and let's be clear I don't want you
to go out and rob some store get
arrested and say Evan Carmichael told me
I need more bad influences in my life
but what I want you to do is have some
influences in your life that help you
stretch that helped you get
uncomfortable and ultimately help you
become the best version of yourself see
growing up you're conditioned to act a
certain way to think a certain way
you're conditioned to think some things
are good and conditioned to think some
things are bad and it's really really
really hard to break free of your chains
of conditioning or if you want to be the
best version of yourself you want to
have a big impact on the world you want
to build an amazing company you're gonna
have to break free you're gonna have to
expand your comfort zone and not just
live in the bubble that you grew up in
you know I'll get criticized on my
channel for posting videos of Kanye West
people say what a douchebag that guy is
I'll get criticized at posting videos
about Donald Trump and say what an
egomaniac that guy is I'll get
criticized by people for posting videos
of Steve Jobs and they say that guy
treated his employees like crap and was
such a micromanager and people say how
do you look up to these people you know
I thought you had a good moral compass
how do you look up to these guys in your
you're making them your heroes and
posting them on your channel and the
thing for me is I don't want to be those
guys right people ask me how do how do I
want to be like what do I want to be
like Donald Trump and Kanye West I don't
want to be like that I want to be the
best version of me and when I grew up I
had certain conditionings myself as well
and those influences you know Kanye
West and Donald Trump and Steve Jobs and
their ability to think bigger and push
boundaries and and push against the
establishment that wasn't what I grew up
in and so learning from them helps me be
the best version of myself and helps me
have a much bigger impact so while other
people might be looking at those guys
and saying man those guys are bad
influences on me bad influences on my
kids bad influence on my friends you can
take elements from them and apply it to
your life to have a bigger impact and
make you a better person so I want you
to go out today and find more bad
influences people who might challenge
how you think people who do things a
little bit differently and by learning
from them apply it to your life in a
good way that can have a positive impact
belief thank you guys for watching my
question of the day today is I want to
know who the bad influences are in your
life bad influences but in a good way
share it in the comments below I'm very
curious to see what you guys come up
with and of course if you liked this
video and you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the newsletter
and the channel thank you so much for
watching have a fantastic day continue
to believe and I'll see you again start
your day with me tomorrow morning for
another inspirational entrepreneur video
belief